uh you know thanks for being here i
don't want to embarrass you but i'm
going to bring up something that
happened to you uh not too long ago
which uh
many men would uh would be thrilled to
have happened to them okay uh you were
named one of people magazine's
sexiest men alive
apparently uh narrowly edging me out
apparently barely yes
right at the uh why is that funny uh
yeah
never seen them so happy we have like
three older brothers like me too it's
like
they say oh one of people's sexiest man
who was the the sexiest jackass
yeah that's isn't that what a brother
would say exactly exactly
as they're beating you with a coconut
the only the only challenge with that is
working it into every conversation that
i ever had
anywhere all the time for the rest of
your life yeah it sucks when you're
talking to somebody about
it then somebody else joins the
conversation and you have to seamlessly
find some way to work it in again
without having the other person leave
yeah uh yeah
no it's you know what you i got in
trouble last time you brought up a
magazine
thing here last time you were on the
show i held up you were in another
magazine
where you would like they had your abs
or something killer abs and i showed a
picture
and uh it caused you embarrassing caused
you a problem um
well no i was just joking around i don't
know why it popped into my head but i
said uh
i said oh yeah there i am with my shirt
off home and i exhale i
turn into tom arnold right right ha ha
whatever i
leave the show right fly all the way
back to los angeles
walk into my apartment building right
through the lobby and who's standing
there but tom arnold
no really yeah and he just lost
50 pounds and um he's like so he's
looking good i know i was like tom i'm
so sorry i don't know why you popped in
my head i was talking about you earlier
and you just popped into my head for
some reason and
he's like such a great he's such a great
guy i know him anyway i mean he's a nice
guy such a sport such a sweetheart
just lost 50 pounds and that little like
verbal judo move just and negated all
his hard work
and uh and then uh and then so i went up
and i'm feeling just
like friggin awful right and i go up to
my apartment and i order up a really
nice bottle of champagne and send it to
him
and then the next day i see him in the
lobby again and he says you know ryan
you must be the only guy in the united
states that doesn't know i'm a
recovering alcoholic
no no oh you're
you're trying so hard to be a good guy
yeah and it's just not working yeah not
so much
well let's talk about this this is must
be exciting you were just at the berlin
film festival
and um i i any opportunity i get to go
anywhere
in it travel the world i'm fascinated uh
i love it
but i'm curious you have a great sense
of humor but i'm curious if it
translates like i would imagine
whenever i read an interview with you
you're funny but you're over in berlin
talking to the foreign press does it
translate
no it's it's weird when you're doing
like irony doesn't really translate or
sarcasm as well i mean
you do these interviews doing a lot of
them you kind of joke around you have
some fun with it but uh
i uh uh i remember i was at the press
conference for this movie definitely
maybe and
they said uh uh ryan what was it like
working with abigail breslin
yeah who's uh abigail she's 10 years old
she's
a little from little miss sunshine
incredible young girl and i said well
she's a fantastic actor i mean she's
like judy dench in good makeup
yeah and then they just kind of look
like this they
but um abigail she's um she's like a
ten-year-old she's not judy dench
it's yeah um
i was 12 when i started this interview
uh just
dying on this press card you're just
like the most boring
just wrote from then on they just write
down everything you say literally and
they're all wearing monocles
exactly yeah yeah she insane actor ryan
reynolds comes to journalism
talks nonsense he jibber jabbers yeah uh
you let's talk about abigail breslin for
a second she plays your
daughter yeah in the film and uh i'm
curious because
you need it's such a delicate chemistry
as an actor you need to have when you're
working with someone who's 10 years old
did you get to know her at all
beforehand to yeah
um you know i was nervous i mean you
know when you're working with a child
actor you
first thing you think is i want to take
my life with fire right uh
but uh um you know there's that there's
that famous saying by wc feels never
worked with kids or dogs
this was like the exact opposite
experience she was such a doll but i
remember
i was nervous the producers called me
before and they said we want you to hang
out with abigail and you know go out i
was like really
yeah all right we'll go do something uh
uh so they set up this day we went out
to the museum of natural history she
wants to see the turtles and she drags
me across the
the park central park all the way into
fao schwartz
i'm in there i'm just longing for death
uh and uh and uh really you're longing
for the death really
um so i uh i i i
i'm like okay we gotta get out of here
abby so let's uh i buy her a stuffed
giraffe and
we leave and i pay for i leave as i'm
leaving i look at the receipt and it's
it's
300 for the giraffe
like i just wanted to gather somebody
and look at the price and i'm like this
is
you could get a real giraffe
less money than this and i said to abby
this thing was 300 bucks
this is crazy and she's like wow yeah
and her mom walks up and she says ryan
um bought me a uh
a stuffed toy it cost 300 what an
idiot and i was like at that moment i
felt
hopelessly in love with this that's a
smart kid yeah i'm kidnapping you and
keeping you for the rest of my life
you really plan to kidnap a child
stop him